y
[Música]
más de 60 personas murieron hoy en mi
amar por disparos de las fuerzas de
seguridad durante nuevas protestas
mientras el ejército celebra el día de
las fuerzas armadas tras presidir un
desfile militar el líder de la junta que
tomó el poder por la fuerza el primero
de febrero reiteró su promesa de
realizar elecciones pero sin dejar claro
cuándo
cientos de venezolanos continúan
llegando a colombia huyendo de
operaciones militares contra presuntas
disidencias de la ex guerrilla
colombiana de las farc y denunciando
abusos del ejército bolivariano y el
asesinato de civiles
representantes del congreso de
estadounidense viajaron a la frontera
sur para pedir al presidente joe biden
una solución al aumento del flujo de
emigrantes que quieren pasar desde
méjico los demócratas de mandar una
humanidad para los niños que viajan sin
compañía y los republicanos culparon a
la administración por reversar políticas
de tropa
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo
las fuerzas de seguridad de mianmar
dispararon y mataron a más de 60
manifestantes en otra jornada de
represión brutal de la junta militar que
celebra hoy el día de las fuerzas
armadas para los civiles que piden
democracia es el día de la vergüenza del
ejército que desde el golpe militar del
primero de febrero ha matado a más de
300 personas pese a la violencia del
líder de la junta dijo que los oficiales
se protegerán a la gente y afirmó que
habrá elecciones pero no dijo cuándo
las fuerzas armadas de mianmar muestran
su músculo militar tanques cañones
misiles marcan el ritmo de la ceremonia
del día de las fuerzas armadas el
general mina online pasa revista sus
tropas desde el golpe de estado
concentra todos los poderes el día de
las fuerzas armadas conmemora la
resistencia de los militares contra la
ocupación japonesa en 1942 sin embargo
este año la demostración de fuerza
parece dirigirse al monumento de
desobediencia civil no debemos aceptar
las reivindicaciones por la vía del
terrorismo ya que pueden perturbar la
tranquilidad del país cuando levantemos
las disposiciones del estado de alarma
organizaremos elecciones libres y justas
para transferir las responsabilidades
gubernamentales pero sin un calendario
fijo y frente a la represión mortal del
ejército
los manifestantes persisten con las
protestas este 27 de marzo se han
organizado nuevas movilizaciones la
policía respondió con fuego real que
causó decenas de muertos el día
anterior con la vista puesta en esta
jornada el ejército había difundido un
mensaje a través de la televisión del
estado no mueran en vano según distintas
asociaciones desde el golpe de estado
del 1 de febrero más de 300 personas han
fallecido y alrededor de 3000 han sido
detenidas mientras tanto la presión de
la comunidad internacional no tiene
demasiada incidencia cada resolución de
la onu es bloqueada por rusia o china en
el consejo de seguridad de hecho estos
dos países han sido los únicos en mandar
delegaciones para asistir al desfile
militar
vamos a colombia donde según las
autoridades es cerca de 4000 venezolanos
han llegado al territorio desde el
pasado domingo huyendo de una serie de
operativos militares por parte del
ejército de venezuela contra campamentos
ilegales y grupos armados colombianos
los migrantes denuncian graves abusos
por parte del ejército venezolano
incluyendo el asesinato de inocentes el
informe desde andre a amaya
cruzan el río arauca en balsa huyen de
una serie de operaciones militares en
venezuela por parte del ejército el
desplazamiento masivo de venezolanos
comenzó el 21 de marzo luego de que
tropas militares bolivarianas lanzarán
una ofensiva aérea y terrestre contra
grupos armados ilegales en el municipio
de la victoria ubicada en el estado de
apure frente a la ciudad colombiana de
arauquita algunos migrantes denuncian
que las fuerzas venezolanas incurren en
falsos positivos quedando no me podía
quedar porque lo están matando a uno por
lo menos unos señores que quedaron unos
vecinos los mataron y le pusieron unos
uniformes del ejército venezolano y los
hicieron pasar por guerrilleros el
fiscal general de venezuela prometió
investigar las denuncias y sancionar a
los responsables
en colombia el desplazamiento de miles
de venezolanos ha agravado la crisis
humanitaria en los albergues
improvisados en medio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 alrededor de 4000 personas han
estado ya en el municipio hoy recibimos
una
gran afluencia de personas también que
venían desde la victoria estaba puré y
la verdad pues estamos contribuyendo
para que ellos estén aquí con toda
tranquilidad esta semana colombia
expresó su preocupación por la situación
en la frontera e instó a la comunidad
internacional a contribuir con ayuda
para los desplazados por su parte el
ministro de exteriores de venezuela
respondió en twitter rechazando las
declaraciones de la cancillería
colombiana y en un comunicado aseguró
que las operaciones militares se han
hecho contra campamentos ilegales de
grupos armados colombianos venezuela
informó además de la muerte de dos
soldados la detención de un líder de un
grupo armado ilegal y la captura de
otras 32 personas colombia es el
principal destino de los migrantes
venezolanos que huyen de la crisis en
febrero anunció que otorgaría un estatus
de protección de 10 años a cerca de 17
millones de personas del país vecino
en noticias de eeuu este viernes dos
grupos de congresistas visitaron la
frontera sur del país republicanos y
demócratas están de acuerdo en que
existe actualmente una crisis
humanitaria en la frontera por el arribo
masivo de inmigrantes principalmente
menores no acompañados pero no están de
acuerdo en quién es el responsable
los demócratas señalan la herencia de la
hera trump mientras que la oposición
ataca las políticas de la nueva
administración veamos
demócratas y republicanos visitaron la
frontera sur de eeuu
su visita llegó con narrativas dispares
en un momento en el que el país registra
su mayor flujo de migrantes en las
últimas dos décadas para los
republicanos representados por john
cornyn y ted cruz el tour sirvió para
exponer la gravedad de la situación lo
que nos trae aquí ahora es esta crisis
humanitaria inmediata esto es la
consecuencia directa de las decisiones
políticas de la administración de byd en
preparar la construcción del muro que
volver a capturar y liberar migrantes y
acabar con la política de quedarse en
méxico paralelamente los demócratas de
la delegación del congreso vieron una
rueda de prensa tras su visita a una
instalación de acogida para niños
migrantes que llegaron solos a la
frontera sur con tejas
su prioridad asegurarse de que los niños
están siendo tratados con humanidad hay
más aun aguas
childs
like this' que yo misma fue una niña que
como estos niños de la violencia
desmesurada situaciones que creo que a
menudo olvidamos aquí en el confort de
eeuu
gire en dar confort en la united states
por su parte joe biden recurrió a kamala
harris para ponerla al frente del reto
de acabar con el problema migratorio
desde la casa blanca una problemática a
la que califica de temporada ya que es
la época del año más segura para viajar
seguimos en estados unidos el presidente
joe biden calificó de ataque flagrante a
la constitución la ley aprobada por las
autoridades del estado de georgia que
afecta a la normativa electoral estatal
la legislación que restringe ampliamente
las votaciones por correo fue impulsada
por los republicanos grupos de derechos
civiles presentaron una demanda federal
contra el proyecto que es señalado por
los demócratas como un método para
reducir la influencia de los votantes
afroamericanos nazaret aplaza nos cuenta
más
un golpe los cimientos del sistema
electoral en georgia tras la luz verde
del congreso local el gobernador
republicano firmó y convirtió en ley un
polémico proyecto que modifica
radicalmente las leyes electorales en el
estado which will begin working
comenzamos a trabajar con la cámara y el
senado en nuevas reformas para facilitar
la votación y dificultar las trampas el
proyecto que promueve para convertirlo
en ley acceso a la controversial ley
impone diversas restricciones a la
votación por correo como la
obligatoriedad de presentar una
identificación con foto reducir el
tiempo para solicitar las boletas para
el voto en ausencia y limitar la
ubicación de las urnas y su tiempo de
acceso a ellas
la normativa reducirá además el poder de
la junta electoral y la del secretario
de estado
brad trofense berger quien rechazó los
intentos de trump por revertir los
resultados de noviembre dará más poder a
la legislatura actualmente de manos
republicanas otra de las polémicas
medidas es la prohibición de suministrar
alimentos y bebidas en las largas filas
de votación
es enfermizo
decidir en algunos estados que no se
puede llevar agua a las personas que
hacen fila esperando para votar y que no
habrá votaciones por correo en las
circunstancias más difíciles la
oposición demócrata denuncia que la ley
busca restringir el acceso al voto por
correo de la población afroamericana en
las últimas elecciones 1,3 millones de
votantes en el estado recurrieron a esta
modalidad de votación algo que fue clave
para convertir a georgia histórico
bastión republicano en uno de los
estados bisagra que llevó a bardem a la
presidencia también en el territorio que
neutralizó el poder conservador en el
senado los republicanos han impulsado
una serie de reformas a las leyes
electorales en varios estados como
arizona michigan o florida bajo
infundados señalamientos de fraude
impulsados por el propio donald trump
tras su derrota historiadores franceses
publicaron un informe condenatoria que
expone los fallos de francia durante el
genocidio de ruanda que vio como 800.000
personas en su mayoría de la etnia tutsi
fueron masacrados en 1994 la principal
conclusión del informe es que
francia tiene una responsabilidad
abrumadora por sus fallos militares y
políticos pero sin embargo no acusa al
país de complicidad en el genocidio
27 años después del genocidio de ruanda
un grupo de historiadores franceses
publicó un informe afirmando que francia
tiene una responsabilidad abrumadora en
el genocidio las autoridades francesas
apoyaron al régimen que era racista
corrupto y violento se afirma en el
informe basándose en el argumento de que
los rebeldes tutsis eran una amenaza
para los hutus
el gobierno francés armó y entrenó a
estos últimos estados que los
consideraba sus aliados
las autoridades francesas instaron
políticas que estaban completamente
desconectadas de la realidad estaban
basadas en divisiones étnicas y ese
acercamiento empeoró la crisis el ciclo
de la chj de nye que el informe denuncia
la ceguera de francia ante las
preparaciones del genocidio en 2019
france24 emitió el testimonio del
antiguo jefe de la cooperación militar
en ruanda dijo que él había alertado a
sus superiores sobre el inminente riesgo
de genocidio pero francia no hizo nada
entre varios puntos del informe destaca
el hecho de que francia se negara a
arrestar a los líderes youtube cuando
entraron en una zona segura creada para
las víctimas
andante francés surgió a parís el
permiso para detenerlos pero el
presidente francés se negó tal y como
explicó el antiguo jefe de su oficina
las naciones unidos nos dieron un
mandato humanitario no uno judicial no
estábamos trabajando para una corte
ruanda acusó a francia de complicidad en
el genocidio pero el informe de los
historiadores franceses dice que ningún
archivo corrobora esta teoría los
ministros de relaciones exteriores de
china e irán en firmaron un acuerdo de
cooperación de 25 años en una ceremonia
transmitida en vivo por la televisión
estatal el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de china wang yi realiza la
visita del estado para fortalecer la
cooperación y antes de la firma se
reunió con el presidente de hasan rohan
y se espera que el pacto incluye
inversiones chinas en sectores clave
como energía e infraestructura por valor
de 400 mil millones de dólares a cambio
beijing espera que teherán garantice un
suministro estable de petróleo y gas a
precios competitivos
en etiopía hay un anuncio que podría
conducir a un avance después de meses de
guerra el primer ministro había me dijo
que las fuerzas militares eritreas se
retiraran de la región de de tigre en
disputa armada desde el pasado noviembre
las declaraciones llegan después de que
el mandatario admitiera que se han
cometido crímenes de guerra durante los
meses de enfrentamientos pero sin
atribuir responsabilidades marinas
ardilla nos amplia
luego de meses de conflicto y tensiones
constantes el ejército eritreo acordó
retirar sus tropas de la disputada
región de tigre en el norte de etiopía
fronteriza con eritrea así lo anunció el
primer ministro etíope habia hammett que
esta semana tras meses de negación
admitió la presencia de militares
eritreos en el territorio desde
noviembre de 2020 con la escalada de los
ataques dos más el gobierno de eritrea
ha aceptado retirar sus tropas de la
frontera etíope la fuerza de defensa
nacional de etiopía se hará cargo de la
vigilancia de las zonas fronterizas con
efecto inmediato el premio nobel de la
paz etíope no informó de cuántos
soldados eritreos se movilizaron pero
testigos estiman que podrían ser miles
además reconoció que durante los
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas rebeldes
tigrillas se cometieron crímenes de
guerra sin aceptar responsabilidades
tanto el ejército eritreo como el etíope
han sido señalados de saqueos masacres y
violaciones
la gente fue asesinada por las balas las
armas pesadas en los tanques disparaban
y las casas fueron quemadas en este
momento la gente huyó si los atrapaban
los mataban era el ejército eritreo el
que hacía
este viernes naciones unidas- consiguió
entrar a los campos de refugiados
eritreos en tigres por primera vez desde
noviembre
durante una misión conjunta en la zona
con la oficina de coordinación de
asuntos humanitarios de la onu
encontramos ambos campamentos
completamente destruidos y todas las
instalaciones humanitarias saqueadas y
vandalizadas acnur está profundamente
preocupada por el bienestar de los
refugiados eritreos que residían allí
todos han huido de los campos
el conflicto en etiopía estalló el
pasado 4 de noviembre desde entonces
casi un millón de etíopes y refugiados
eritreos han huido al vecino sudán hasta
aquí el informativo pero volvemos en
minutos siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]